bien bien attendant en attendant que ces
trois chefs s'installe je vais présenter
donc les les autres par nous
m
comme il en est
non
pas dire 'je voulais voulait dire
quelque chose je vais partir alors
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire et puis
alors nous sommes des cheminots de la
gare de lyon qui sont venus vous rendez
vous est à la gare de lyon ils viennent
d'avoir des graines toute la semaine et
bien je pense qu'il est normal que les
cheminots viennent s expliquer un peu
est ce que vous êtes en train bleu un
restaurant de luxe et bien nous pourrons
peut-être parler de nos salaires puisque
nous revendiquons sur le salaire nous
aimerions aussi que passer en direct sur
l'écran parce que nous aimerions que les
cheveux que les usagers que les
téléspectateurs connaissent nos
revendications
oui nous aimerions savoir que nous
demandons le salaire minimum de 1000
francs par mois
alors il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
connu un agent du niveau 1 depuis par
niveau de l'exécution ne gagnent pas 500
francs par mois il faut savoir commis un
agent qualifié du niveau de vie ne pas
lui non plus l'agent qui peut avoir
quatre ans d'ancienneté qui peut avoir
trois ans d'apprentissage d'un centre
saint siège ne les gagne pas il faut le
savoir tout cela
nous sommes venus le dire nous sommes
venus dire qu'ils me demandent à 104
euros annuels car nous n'avons nous en
sommes encore sans repos nous avons
passé 1 4 po on dit que le cheminot
santana beaucoup de congés bien là on
s'aperçoit que ce n'est pas vrai j'ai
voulu protester
ouais d'accord avait coûté voilà chose
faite et bien
donc mettons à 100 nous avons encore
beaucoup de choses à dire non mais bien
sur ma faim vous pouvez pas tout lire la
vie et nous n'en dirai les choses que le
comité s'est passé s'est passé gentile
pourra dès que j'entre il est bien
bombée fruits cheminots
trévisan
non mon passé
alors
robert ambert courtine ont dit courtine
maintenant chroniqueur gastronomique si
cela échoue aux portes closes pseudonyme
de la reynière et vous êtes auto
nombreux ouvrages notamment le cahier
des recettes walheim et grecque est paru
aux éditions laffont le gîte